est ce qu'ils montrent des enfants
bien sûr ça mon bien des enfants aussi
bien que moi un moment très très bien
oui tu vas voir cela long d'un fil
j'ai fait l'école des fans ouais j'ai
fait comme des femmes décalage
j'avais à l'époque j'avais 5 ans
habitait c'était dave ça s'est passé
l'émission elle-même ça s'est bien passé
mais bon pour pour passer à l'émission
jacques martin était un peu spéciale
pour avec les enfants leur demander des
trucs un peu bizarres
vous allez manger des choses bizarres à
vous à l'époque ouais moi par exemple
bajaur des attouchements des choses
comme ça quoi
carrément [ __ ] de temps de parler ce
genre de choses c'est tellement
traumatisante que quelque part a cédé 3
face de vous aujourd'hui vous lui diriez
quoi [ __ ] je dirais espèce de gros
dégueulasse et je lui mettrais une
énorme gifle et je dirais qu'il ya
beaucoup bouleversé ma vie en fait
campagne de diffamation contre chaque
matin on a besoin de témoignages vous
dites que vous avez participé à l'école
des fans et vous aviez 5 ans et vous via
les îles essayer de vous violez hockey
attention va tourner et moins jeunes
vous avez fait l'école des fans vous
aviez quel âge où j'avais 5 ans et je
chantais très bien à l'époque s'est très
mal passé je crois savoir c'est
effectivement très mal passé jacques
martin m'a violée je soutiens comme avec
il est ouvert la brèche si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi car depuis ou 7 fait
tiré par foucault et sabatier sébastien
sébastien aussi hommage à la légende mon
chapeau je te remercie pour tout ce que
tu as fait pour moi est bon mais ça va
quoi chaussures mise quand même de mes
émotions je n'ai jamais remise
voici de nombreuses victimes des enfants
qui sort du casting de jacques martin et
qui se sont tous fait plus ou moins
violés ils ont tous été victimes
d'attouchements des images terribles
alors là c'est fils je peux plus faire
de l'école des fans et corrections de ne
rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous
il m'était impossible eux